we'll close it out with some debate club
did we answer a question what were we
supposed to do do they want to know if
they want to put the dog down or not is
that the patient oh my I don't know what
the show is anymore you guys found it
pretty well I think
mission accomplished trying to help and
look I'm just saying in some cultures
man a dog is a food that's fine
meat is a meat that's if a person dies I
feel like in some cultures elite you
facts you know you got to have what you
can have the only a defender dude if I'm
dyin bro I'm eating you ask first
I felt that in my that's how alive I
still AM I could feel it when you said
don't say it like that again so I mean
that's a lot yeah
feed the whole goddamn true pastor G hi
woody yeah all right well hey guys this
is Ashley from New Jersey in honor of
President's Day weekend I have debate
club for you who was a better president
Honest Abe Lincoln or I cannot tell a
lie
George Washington gang gang buzz buzz
you know what I'm gonna say I was just
happy to be here right now
appreciate y'all I hope y'all choose the
right answer ready set go
y'all gotta go with us
[Laughter]
who was a better president that she's
saying I boyana save man you know what's
weird about Honest Abe is there's no
record of his voice but we all think
it's seven scores and seven you know
super low yeah they have no idea what it
is some people think it was really high
just the movies made it really low I
think Abe I don't know man a well here's
the thing about George you'd be the
first president you had to wear a wig
and wooden teeth ha and also super
racist but was he raises you think oh
yeah
was he he's just what they did back then
yeah you know dude do you think you
would have owned a slave back then or
posi you know growing up yeah I don't
know it's crazy hey man I gotta go Abe
Abe also a vampire killer was he's
really a did you ever seen the movie
phenomenal movie I'm Abraham Lincoln
vampire killer I've never seen it you
know it catch the rerun on FX
god yes I start [ __ ] living dude yeah
gonna [ __ ] PPR and AFL games where
the hell it is and start Abe was a PBR
fan this was literally a guy in the
crowd at the Pro Bowl right a man
brought look at a bright there huh Oh
taking in some beer odds right there
baby
you purposely dress like Abe Lincoln
that's just his vibe I think that's him
that's a yeah
he's got to be somewhere dude I'll get
your own eye he put his head back
together throw an identity bro brothers
head he got look I'll say this man I've
been an honest Abe's home that he lived
in in Illinois they actually preserved
their whole neighborhood the
neighborhood that he like little yeah
they preserved so you can walk around
like his neighborhood and all the houses
are from like wasn't he like the AC five
or six six two tall and had that hat
he was Dikembe Mutombo back then yeah
and he would keep his notes in his hat
he would keep notes in special documents
in his hat it was gangster and he had a
lot of cats and he would pet the cats
all the time at home they said I don't
like I said it was a little suspect yeah
the way he really had a lot of cats
India I don't know the more you know so
deftly aid based on the cast due to the
cat look it was a visionary man Abe I
think you gotta go wave I guess I think
it just uh it was a little more also
like five dollar bills more than one you
feel me haha done babe what do you guys
say there in the booth huh
Abraham Lincoln hey I should palyer you
don't hear a lot about George Washington
getting forgot about you a lot about the
old George Washington these days doing
well dude somebody just they just
somebody just spray painted a bunch of
graffiti on Plymouth Rock yesterday they
said yeah that's offensive that's crazy
your boy a drunk he's he's all been our
face man Daniel day-lewis play dumb yeah
who is the last play scene that played
George Washington maybe Frank Caliendo
maybe Plymouth Rock vandalize house
they're not security around that [ __ ] I
know right are we doing inside job come
on no yeah you right it's etiquette look
like what they spray print like get dick
on or something dicks is always some go
to ship for people it is
yeah they spray those dick son stuff
right mile from it no you're right yeah
that's what there's a man in Arizona
right now that
like spray painting dicks on all the
walls yes yeah somebody spray-painted on
it to rock but the rock is one of
several monuments around the Plymouth
waterfront and what did they somebody
wrote something on it what they write on
there oh and they put some love some
blood they just trying to add a little
color to it you know yeah put a damn
wolf by it or something they can't get
something to guard the damn rock put a
Rottweiler on wheels like that [ __ ] yeah
yeah and look if you have a dog that's
still on four legs rocky gotta tighten
your game up they have dogs out there on
two legs rolling on 11 all-wheel drive
skates what else we got Nick that's it
yeah I was laughing so much I don't know
what happened really all I remember is
some dogs big old nut oh that's it and
then him having bat wings and I'm flying
around the lawn dude a lot of all I
remember this episode well Brendan a lot
of animals are starting to be cross
pollinated and stuff so it wouldn't be
crazy to see a bad a bad dog you know
down the future you know make sense but
we'll see man
[Music]
King nothing
[Music]